UK retailers have seen their sales jump
more than expected last month rebounding
to pre-pandemic levels it comes as
consumer confidence Rises to its highest
level in a decade but in a week when
households faced more financial pain
with interest rates rising and inflation
on the up again
so let's take a look then at the numbers
and retail sales increased by 1.2
percent in February following a rise of
0.9 in January
so let's get our business presenter Ian
King's take on all of this so in retail
sales figures going up what'd you make
of it
well these are appreciably uh better
numbers than the market have been
expecting from in a modest rise in
retail sales have been anticipated but
uh nothing of this magnitude so resale
sales jumping month for month now for
the second uh consecutive month the
January figure was revised Higher by the
office for National statistics what's
really interesting in the uh breakdown
is that uh the strongest growth was
actually seen in non-food that was up by
some 2.4 month on month and the office
for National statistics suggesting that
discount retailers have had a
particularly uh good time of it what
they mean by that is the likes of
poundland and budget stores of that
persuasion so clearly no surprise there
given that some consumers are shopping
around and trying to save money non-food
sales were up by some point nine percent
during the month uh month on month and
the office for National statistics is
suggesting there that this might be down
to uh consumers for going takeaways and
restaurant meals in favor of uh eating
in more and that's her potentially why
food sales are higher there is a slight
uh question mark over the numbers though
in that they're not particularly
consistent with the distributive trade
survey that the CBI published in late
February which suggested that retail
sales during the month were pretty flat
but I think it's an encouraging sign
that consumers are still spending uh
particularly uh in the wake of some of
the other news that we've had this week
for example the higher than expected
inflation number that came out for
February earlier this weekend of course
the rise in interest rates yesterday
from the bank of England